say cause there's no way you can read my
mind
it's like doctor strange i'm complex and
madness did you see it yeah i liked it
you haven't seen it yet did you see it
yeah i wouldn't put it in my top five oh
wow of doctor strange movies
yeah it's number two yeah yeah
uh yeah i had a lot to do
and a lot to serve and sam raim i know
why you liked it because you love sam
raimi probably so they played a they
were very non-marveling that's why you
liked it all right
if we're going to do a doctor strange
multiverse what's it called madness of
multiple what's that
i don't know multi-man multi-man all
right so um let's do a movie review okay
claude i want your take too even though
you didn't okay
you have to still give your take so
number one okay
here's what i liked about it all right
obviously bruce campbell
great cameo okay he's in all the samurai
muse movie and i guess
watching the movie i was just like
didn't give a [ __ ] until bruce campbell
came up on screen
so that's number one or number two right
um
it's not great but
there's some
cl cliche um
because of
the multiverse you know i mean um
dynamic in the movie
you can now break so many different
rules sure
right so like in if you haven't seen the
new spider-man movie then
spoiler alert but because of the
multiverse thing you can bring back toby
and um
garfield andrew garfield who i like as
an actor by the way it was so good fully
imagined garfield the cat for some
reason
wait i'm sorry in this yeah
yeah imagine
a poor portal opens up toby maguire
walks in and another portal opens up and
just an orange cat
with lasagna on his face comes in rugby
so
so there's that you know i mean rule
that they can have now so now when
you're watching
you know i mean uh doctor strange
there's a couple of
strange
cameos in it
you didn't think any of some of them
were kind of cool though no
i think it's weird interesting because
it's like i know why it's for like the
applause of effect because i remember
being in the theater with jules and
seeing toby and andrew garfield because
it was such a surprise people were yeah
and we're like
i don't even know why but you know
i was doing that right with this one me
and gene
looked at each other and went
the last the last reveal of a certain
group of people our audience went they
started laughing
yeah because he was like he was about to
die
i have to it's two weeks this is two
weeks in
okay fine you're right all right so
because of the multiverse aspects of
these movies now you can bring people in
from other movies that have no relation
to the avengers or
right still marvel though still marvel
right so you had
elastic man what's his name the last one
we had john krasinski as a
doctor from the fantastic fantasy poor
guy right mr fantastic mr fantastic yeah
he comes in
and people were like oh
right people were about you're white
what yeah yeah
and then the last reveal
is
it was a pant like i went
the music you hear the little music yeah
it was
professor x patrick stewart patrick
stewart yeah he comes in with his
wheelchair but he looks like he's dead
he's so old very old
you know i love him as an actor he's my
favorite there was a little bit of a
concern there right
but um
and then people were like because
younger kids didn't see
x-men attachment like who's the old man
the crippled old man you know what i
mean
and that was a little weird but um
yeah you know right you're right it's
not the best one but not the worst still
fun yeah still fun it's still fun what's
the matter george just making sure it's
it's funny george when i talk
as of late i've been observing you
and there's a lot of drifting
design looking at monitors a lot of
looking at your watch looking your
gadgets is am i saying stuff that's not
riveting
no i was just making sure you were
everybody's in frame everything's good
i'd check it every five minutes to make
sure everything's oh excuse me kurosawa
everything needs to be perfect on the
screen i'm always
riveted by you you're riveting to me too
as well and it's about half an hour past
my bedtime now so is it really he sleeps
early now oh so you're like daddy yeah
you're a daddy this kid wakes up at 6
a.m every morning no matter what
he is cute man
yeah and he there is a little bit of
resemblance you know man i can see a
little bit of george in him oh thank you
but um
i see the good part too
mostly mostly your wife yeah yeah oh
there we go yeah yeah